2024 will be a decisive pivotal year in
the war in Ukraine which in my opinion
will not only decide the outcome of the
war but also whether the current
rules-based world order Will Survive
following the failed Ukrainian summer
counter offensive Western 8 has visibly
declined what's worse Putin sympathizers
in the US and the EU the Republican
party and the Hungarian government are
delaying two key extremely important
eight packages in some sense we are at
the lowest point however there is reason
to believe that this is a temporary
State of Affairs and that the C bridge
will be dropped in 2024 how EX ex L well
this video is here to explain the topics
I'll be covering are the following the
battlefield situation meaning where each
side is militarily and what's happening
along the front line the political
situation in Russia Ukraine and the West
in terms of the war the goals and
potential end games of each side and the
risks they face then I will briefly talk
about the idea of Western Game Changer
Tech I'll cover the potential special
decommissioning operation of the catch
bridge and the current prognosis as to
how the war might end finally I'll
recommend channels not to follow for war
updates and channels that are worth
following so let's Dive In A lot has
been said about who's winning the war in
Ukraine Russia took over a street west
of donet while obviously Russia is
making progress and winning the war
Ukraine threw some soldiers over to
nipro well obviously ukrainians are just
days away from a massive lending
operation where they'll take back Crimea
in reality the war has bed down with
neither side able to achieve
breakthrough some have characterized
this as a Ukrainian defeat and or
Russian Victory but that's a
misunderstanding of the situation as a
reminder of how we got here the first
big Russian Blitz Creek Was Defeated
ukrainians beat Russians out of Kev har
and hero and then helped solve the
overcrowding problem in the Russian
prison system by slowly pulling out of
bakot then a Ukrainian counter offensive
followed in the South which was halted
by the Russians before it could achieve
any major breakthroughs in the meantime
visually confirmed Russian Hardware
losses stand at around 14,000 and
Russian Manpower losses are between 315
and 360,000 according to Vladimir Putin
Russia currently holds around 18% of
Ukrainian territory and is importing
shells possibly Rockets of questionable
quality from North Korea so any reports
about the supposed Russian Victory or
Ukrainian defeat should be considered
with this context in mind Russians in
the meantime are conducting large
offensives around abka which consists of
commanders yoloing their troops into
Ukrainian lines the only noteworthy
Russian success recently was the
Takeover of Maringa west of donet a
settlement that has been contested for a
decade and which is just a patch of
rubble at this point the General Dynamic
now seems to be ukrainians digging in
and defending while Russians Reen their
vad are offensive across multiple
locations the other hot location outside
of abka being the Northeast edge of hara
blast and in one of these areas based on
videos that surfaced on the 13th of
January apparently Ukrainian Bradley
managed to take out a Russian t90m tank
with its 25 mm Bushmaster AO Cannon you
can find the video via search I want to
avoid showing combat footage since
that's a sure way to get demonetized all
right so who's doing quote unquote
better when comparing the two armies
ukrainians seem to be better equipped
and have higher Morale on average and
they do have a technological Edge in
terms of Hardware Russians on the other
hand compensate for horse equipment by
having numerical superiority in pretty
much everything importantly they have an
absolute share superiority and have an
asymmetrical advantage in terms of long
range Rockets when it comes to Russian
Manpower though the Ukrainian counter
offensive did degrade them quite a lot
in terms of vehicles Russia has more but
they still rely heavily on stock piles
according to covert cabal who bought
satellite images and simply counted the
number of vehicles Russia has stored
every year the number of Russian tanks
in storage sinks by 1,200 with their
latest amount from October 2023 being
3,500 good tanks without obvious signs
of damage and 2,000 additional tanks
that obviously need repairs in terms of
bmps and other fighting Vehicles not
including tanks and artillery Russia had
3,677 BMP stored in Depot and 5,240
similar Vehicles such as btrs mtbs and
so on so that's around 9,000 in total
this is once again according to cover
cabal as of January 2024 orex lists
around 5,000 of such Vehicles lost after
2 years of war which translates to about
2,500 per year in terms of artillery
based on Covert cabal's July 2023
numbers Russia had 7,500 total artillery
in storage and 4,400 self-propelled guns
and they're pulling 3,000 toad artillery
pieces from Storage per year and about
300 self-propelled guns so on all these
fronts we can say that Russia has about
2 to three years left before their
current storage is run out with this
information I'd like to help dispel the
myth that Russia can just keep up this
war indefinitely unless they find a way
to multiply their new production time is
not on their side contrary to what many
commentators would want you to believe
additionally there's a growing lack of
workers in the Russian economy which
I'll discuss in a bit and now let's look
at the political layout of the Ukraine
war in the west attitudes towards
Ukraine seem to have cooled somewhat a
good example is Joe Biden shifting from
as long as it takes to as long as we can
when referring to supporting Ukraine in
the meantime the isolationist
authoritarian friendly far right is
gaining prominence across the west and
those movements are almost universally
pro- Russian the Ukrainian summer
counter offensive failure has only
emboldened those actors 2024 also brings
its own risks with the US elections if
Donald Trump wins the election and
starts connecting an autocracy the US
military will inevitably coup him and
temporarily take control of the
government this will be rather
disruptive in terms of Aid to Ukraine
and might mean a multiple month halt in
supplies while a provisional government
sorts itself out but us support is not
the only one of course recently Britain
announced a 2.5 billion pound Aid
package for example containing
long-range missiles air defense or ter
ammunition and Maritime security put a
pin in that first one especially the
longrange missiles because they'll be
relevant soon despite this Aid the past
months have been the lowest in terms of
Aid provided to Ukraine the failure of
the summer counter offensive therefore
risks becoming a self fulfilling
prophecy where due to a lack of
Battlefield success there is less
political will to provide Aid therefore
Ukraine gets less Aid therefore they
cannot achieve Battlefield success
therefore there is less Aid this should
change however when hopefully EU and US
Aid packages get approved in the coming
weeks but Pro Russian Republicans are
nonetheless a worrying Trend who
represent a new authoritarian movement
on the American right these people are
no longer the usual neoconservatives who
a few weeks ago even criticized Biden
for not doing enough for Ukraine these
new Republicans the mega variety that
are slowly taking over the party are
over overtly sympathizing with faride
dictators across the globe if Trump gets
elected in 2024 these people are
expected to run a mock hopefully that
won't happen because a US military coup
against an authoritarian Mega government
would complicate things in terms of
Ukraine so this is the political
situation in the west now let's look at
Ukraine there is an increasingly visible
conflict between the civilian and
Military leaderships between zalinski
and Zi as the war stopped being an
existential threat and became a question
of do we lose 20% of our territory or
not political maneuvering is back in the
game I've read reports about zinski
skipping the chain of command and
communicating with Ukrainian Frontline
officers directly without zines
knowledge in addition the political
leadership had the brilliant idea of
firing all regional recruitment officers
after one of them got caught in a
corruption Scandal this inevitably
caused Ukrainian recruitment numbers to
tank temporarily at a time when Ukraine
sorely needs fresh troops zelinsky's
office seems to be worried about Z's
popularity and how it might translate to
him becoming a political opponent to
them once the war is over in other words
now that the Mortal danger is over
politics continues as usual but before
any anyone would Panic this doesn't
hamper the Ukrainian war effort that
much so far it's in the nuisance
category where it hopefully remains
otherwise as the war drags on the first
discussions are happening across
Ukrainian Society about how long the war
should go on whether they should concede
at least some territory in exchange for
peace the percentage of those who do not
want concessions is still high around
74% but those willing to accept
conceding territory have risen from 10%
in May 2023 to 19% in December 2023 and
before anyone would judge people for
thinking that try losing a friend for
father or husband in the war or live for
2 years with the fear of losing them
which can basically happen at any moment
another topical issue in Ukraine is
mobilization which seems to be
relatively unpopular understandably so
there is a lack of Manpower in part
because of the aformentioned firing of
all regional recruitment officers there
was also a controversial mobilization
Bill submitted which was deemed poorly
written and unjust the bill has been
withdrawn since then and a better one is
in the works this is an advantage of
democracy bad decisions can be
criticized and forced to be reconsidered
by the people in the meantime the
Ukrainian Ian economy is maintained by
Western in particular EU funds and
despite Victor orban's threats of
derailing support for Ukraine the
situation is not so straightforward
multiple member states took issue with
different aspects of the funding
approach so consensus was needed to
proceed now that this seems mostly done
Ukraine will get monetary Aid and Victor
Orban will be S Steed if needed through
complicated legal processes so despite
all the media hype about Orban and his
obstructionism he really doesn't amount
to more than an annoyance at this moment
now let's take a look at Russia their
political and economic situation the
Russian political system is more stable
than ever it's safe to say that Russia
is under the complete control of the
government Putin increasingly builds his
legitimacy on the war trying to draw a
parallel between the war against the
Nazi invasion of Russia they aren't
particularly bothered by the fact that
back then Nazi Germany attacked them
while now they are the Invaders Russian
Society seems to continue to support
Putin and is generally accepting of the
war according to a leveled up all in
October 2023 20% of Russians supported
the war 29% rather supported it 35%
rather opposed and 15% opposed let's say
near 50-50 ratio but we should also
consider that Putin's current approval
rating is at 83% the tolerance threshold
of Russian Society seems to be General
mobilization which puin seeks to avoid
at all costs so basically people will
tolerate the current state of affairs as
long as they themselves don't get
drafted Russia doesn't need a new wave
of mobilization for now as there are
enough volunteers due to financial
incentives there are also other hidden
incentives such as families of the
diseased getting a brand new Lada if
your husband is violent abusive and so
on here's the chance to get rid of him
and get a new car in the process so once
again the population seems to be largely
on board with or tolerant of the war as
long as it doesn't affect them that much
otherwise Russia has done a decent job
converting into a wartime economy which
is quite stable for the time being I've
seen estimates of it being able to stay
afloat for another two to three years
boring unforeseen factors now let's move
on to more interesting stuff namely the
potential endgame scenarios of the war
as I've said this are is pivotal in
determining to War's outcome so let's
look at the goals of each side the
original Russian goal was the capture
and subjugation of Ukraine and the end
of the pro Western Ukrainian State this
has obviously failed and aside from
public statements the Russian leadership
isn't seriously counting on it the
current revised goal is likely either a
frozen conflict which prevents Ukraine
from joining the EU or NATO or a
ceasefire both allowing Russia to
rebuild its Army and try again the
Ukrainian goal was and still is the
complete liberation of all occupied
territories including Crimea at the
moment the chances of disappear remote
and there are the affir conversations
within Ukrainian Society whether these
goals should be scaled back in exchange
for peace but can there be peace between
Russia and Ukraine currently nobody
seems interested in it and for good
reason you don't give up the fight if
you think you're winning or if you think
you can't afford to lose both SS
represent a mixture of these two lines
of thinking recently there was an
interesting article in the New York
Times however alleging that Russian
officials are starting to broach the
topic of ceasefire in secret the article
writes that a similar thing happened in
the fall of 2022 after ukrainians kicked
the Russians out of the hcave region the
idea then was that Putin would be
satisfied with territories heal at that
time but that he won't concede any of it
are these quiet gestures meaningful or
are they just the usual Bluff to throw
us off I believe they are real but so
far they should not be taken that
seriously Beyond taking a mental note
it's true that Putin is very risk ofs
and that the war being bogged down
includes Russians as well he also knows
that he's not taking Ukraine due to
Western support even if it has been
flagging recently at this point to what
end is the Russian army fighting in
Ukraine storages are emptying out at a
worrying rate heavy equipment losses are
catastrophic and even if they did take
over Ukraine somehow they don't have the
manpower to fight the anoing Insurgency
with this in mind it's plausible that
the Russian leadership would lowkey
start talking about negotiations to
bring up the idea of outlining a plan
for a ceasefire in the midterm maybe
it's a very basic strategy of hedging
your bets in advance that being said
currently Ukraine not liberating the
entirety of its territory looks more
likely than not I'd like to stress that
currently part things can and do change
there is a certain level of War fatigue
in the west and Ukraine plus there is
the looming threat of the 2024 us
elections as us support to Ukraine seems
to correlate with Joe Biden's cognitive
abilities with that in mind let's take a
look at the PO potential endings of the
Ukraine war as I said in the beginning
2024 will likely decide not just the
outcome of the war but whether the
rules-based world order survives or not
if a country can start a war of
territorial conquest and get away with
it then others can do it as well that
would mean the Advent of a new world
order based on might makes right where
strong Nations can do whatever they
please as long as nobody can stop them
in practice this would mean an era of
constant smaller Regional Wars possibly
between nuclear Nations so now let's
look at the potential outcomes of the
Ukraine war the perfect outcome is of
course Ukraine beating Russia with
Western help restoring control over the
entirety of its territory opening the
door to EU and NATO membership the less
perfect outcome is Ukraine conceding
some territory but nonetheless joins the
EU and NATO cementing the peace a subpar
outcome would be Ukrainian territorial
concessions that aren't followed with EU
or NATO memberships instead there would
only be a collection of bilateral
agreements which Russia may or may not
respect wink wink a bad outcome would be
the War ending with a peace agreement
but without any security agreements or
EU membership at that point another
Russian invasion would just be a matter
of time where Russ Russia would use the
next few peaceful years to reorganize
and reconstitute its Army getting ready
for round two a very bad outcome would
be if there wasn't even a peace
agreement if the war simply devolved
into a frozen conflict preventing
Ukraine from rebuilding itself counting
the days till the next inevitable
Russian invasion and finally there is
the catastrophic scenario in that Trump
gets elected in 2024 without anyone
stopping him a far right authoritarian
isolationist US Government pulls out of
NATO essentially collapsing it and
leaves Ukraine to its own devices due to
the lack of Aid ukrainians are gradually
pushed back until the conflict becomes
Frozen with large Russian territorial
gains at that point the rules-based
world order is over as there is no one
left to uphold it further millions of
Ukrainian refugees stream into Europe
and Russia starts to gear up for the
next round but this time Moldova and the
baltics are also on the list at that
point in my opinion we would almost
certainly see an attempted Chinese
invasion of Taiwan as well which of
these outcomes will come true we'll know
more at the end of the year both Russia
and Ukraine face risks along the way
though which will play a large part in
determining the outcome for ukrainians
the risks are manow power issues low
Western support in the form of small Aid
packages and lack of military industrial
output the massive Russian Terror
bombings against civilian infrastructure
and the rise of the far right
authoritarian Pro Russian populists such
as G fielders Victor Orban and the afd
in Germany Russian risks on the other
hand include limited stockpiles and the
increasing lack of good Hardware also
Manpower issues in the economy namely
the millions missing from the labor
market with that said what about Western
gamechanging Tech Ukrainian Pilots are
already training on f-16s they have M1
Abrams Tanks leopards and so on such
Hardware does help a lot especially
f-16s however I wouldn't view them as
Wonder Weapons just like how Russian
isander or kinel missiles didn't
magically win the war for them they only
make things more difficult for the enemy
there are also issues with Ukrainian
equipment namely the leopard tanks which
have a low operational Readiness from
what I could gather it's the lack of
spare parts the fact that the tanks need
to be repaired in Lithuania and that
Ukrainian mechanics weren't properly
trained to maintain them so far the
trend with German tanks and
self-propelled guns seems to be it works
great until it doesn't a common issue
seems to be be overuse and the fact that
NATO Hardware isn't quite configured for
this type of large scale attritional War
Ukraine seems to have or had access to
atams the Army tactical missile system
namely a small batch the US sent them
which was used to nail a Russian Forward
Air Base damaging or destroying multiple
Russian helicopters but we haven't had
information about additional deliveries
since then not to mention ukrainians
received the oldest possible variant the
M39 block one with anti-personal
bomblets that has half the range 165 km
compared to the most modern atcham of
ourland on a personal note I find this
rather infuriating Israel can level the
Gaza Strip with the most modern American
weapons while Ukraine defending itself
against an imperialist invasion gets
only 30-year-old leftovers slated for
decommissioning however Ukraine also
received Storm Shadow missiles from the
UK which aren very useful as we'll soon
see game changers aside what does help
Ukraine is not Wonder Weapons but the
sheer mproduction of shells mortar or
artillery in this area thankfully there
is progress aside from efforts to revive
Ukraine's domestic defense industry
there are plans in the EU for a 100
billion Euro defense fund and to ramp up
shell production to 1 million per year
this progress has hit political snaks so
far many countries are hesitant to pour
money into defense but we'll know more
after the February EU Summit so this is
the current situation the front lines
are mostly static Ukraine is having
issues with Manpower and the
unpopularity of conscription Western
support is low for the time being and
they're suffering from everpresent Amo
shortages on the Russian side of things
conscription is also unpopular and there
are also Manpower issues but on the
economy side with Millions missing from
the labor market additional Russian
problems include the quickly of their
Hardware stocks which unlike shells
cannot be produced that fast or that
quickly there is also the edit problem
of Crimea with that let's talk about the
car Bridge as promised in the beginning
you might have seen the news about
Ukraine destroying the noo cheras aacha
class Landing ship that's the third
destroyed large Landing ship with two
more damage in addition to three other
damaged or destroyed smaller Landing
ships now why would Ukraine focus on
such ships like the noo cheras expanding
valuable and rare Storm Shadow missiles
against it well suppose something
happens to the catch Bridge whereby it's
no longer usable by Road or rail if that
important link is cut Crimea and the
Russian troops in the herone region need
to be supplied somehow so how do you
move supplies across the car state
without a bridge large Landing ships
which Ukraine seems to be targeting it's
not hard to see how such strikes could
be a potential Prelude to the C Bridge
being dropped the US has been hesitant
to supply long-range attam missiles
because they're worried Ukraine would
use them against targets inside official
Russian territory but the Carriage
Bridge is not official Russian territory
so suppose the Americans deliver just a
handful of atams missiles for a very
specific mission in addition Ukraine has
its own domestically produced ballistic
missile theim 2 which has been in
development for a while and there has
been speculation about Ukraine having
already used or rather tested one-on
Russian Targets in the form of a strike
on the saki Airbase in Crimea in August
2022 220 km away from the front line at
that point Ukraine did not have any of
the western longrange missiles a
Ukrainian official stated after the
strike that they used a device
exclusively of Ukrainian manufacturer so
I personally do not rule out a special
decommissioning operation of the CCH
bridge in 2024 this this would somewhat
complicate the situation for Russians
aside from the global PR catastrophe
having to manually Supply Crimea would
siphon away precious logistical
resources not to mention Russian
positions in and around the herone
region would get weaker and now you also
need to supply Russian civilians in
Crimea as well this would of course help
reinvigorate support for Ukraine and
would give the Ukrainian government a
much stronger hand in any future
negotiations but for now this is a
speculation well-informed speculation
but still speculation for the time being
instead of daydreaming about the catch
Bridge what you can do is vote for pro
Ukrainian politicians if you have the
chance or donate to trusted fundraisers
for example for fpv drones but it's also
important to stay informed about the
whole situation unfortunately aside from
trustworthy sources many grifter have
also attached themselves to the Ukraine
war spreading misinformation for
engagement and end Revenue so here are
some of the most notorious accounts that
you should avoid if you want accurate
coverage vagr 24 is a channel you should
immediately unfollow this page is a hub
for sloppy journalism and misinformation
their latest stunt was spreading
unsubstantiated rumors about get us some
of being dead another terrible Source
you should avoid is Chuck fer whose maps
are more military fanfiction than
reality and the worst of the bunch is
yushko who single-handedly started a
global disinformation cycle about Russia
being hours away of starting a nuclear
war if you want to follow trustworthy
sources instead here are some of my
recommendations tatarigami UAA is a
great source with accurate and honest
commentary who isn't afraid to point out
issues within the Ukrainian military and
political system The Institute for the
study of war is of course a go-to for
the battlefield updates Michael Koffman
the god of Ukraine war analysis is also
a must follow I also recommend Andrew
perpetua and his very detailed verified
and geolocated map at map. ukr Daily
update.com there is also Rob Lee who
brings you accurate and verified local
level updates and events finally on
YouTube there is perun who I'm sure many
of you already follow his videos about
the Ukraine war are what this video
aspires to be when it grows up in
closing 2024 will be quite a year for
both Ukraine and the international World
Order much will depend on whether
Western shell production will keep up
what the outcome of the US election will
be a potential strike against the catch
bridge and so on and if you're worried
about the current situation don't be the
battlefield has more or less stabilized
and Ukraine is bound to get more support
hopefully in the short term if you'd
like to worry nonetheless I recommend
starting on the 5th of November this
year once the US presidential election
kicks off in the meantime keep yourself
informed vote for pro Ukraine
politicians and donate to various
trusted Pro Ukraine fundraisers if you
can and or sign up for my patreon thank
you for watching and I'll be seeing you
next
time